thanks for having me uh and welcome to
my presentation glad that so many came
and are interested in envelops I
appreciate that you didn't read out the
title because it's actually a lot of
stuff in there I guess and you probably
all wonder what this talk is going to be
about and I hope to clarify this a
little bit more during my talk so it's
called maximizing efficiency and
scalability in open source ml Ops and um
yeah what this is all about and what
efficiency and scalability are and how
you can use them for ML Ops that's what
basically I want to
explain to you today
so I want to kick things off with uh
with a plot or with a graphic that came
out already in 2015 in a paper called
hidden depth in machine Learning Systems
so I just ask all of you who knows this
and who has already seen this plot
before
okay seems like
I would say half
um yeah it's I to me it's a very seminal
paper which is already eight years old
now
and basically the point that the authors
at that time made was that if you want
to put machine learning into production
um there's actually very little
component that is only about machine
learning so you see this small little
dot this black box in there that's your
ml code and then there's basically 98 or
95 of stuff that you have to build
around it and that's basically
um yeah so one of the big challenges uh
since then and I think this challenge
still exists and it's basically all
about how to put machine learning into
production
just to give you some context what uh
like from which perspective I'm looking
at ml Ops I want to quickly introduce
myself and my company
so a few words about me I'm Paul I
studied systematic musicology and did a
doctor fill in this domain I did a lot
of cognitive studies in musicology and
so at the intersection of cognitive
sciences and and music which was very
interesting but at some point I decided
to move into data science I worked at as
a data scientist in some in-house
positions then later moved to AI
consulting or in data science Consulting
and I'm currently leading the AI and
data science team at data drivers
and we are a small smallish consulting
company based in Hamburg Germany
which is pretty much one a half hour
train ride from Berlin
and the second biggest city in Germany
here don't know much about Hamburg we
were founded in 2015
um
and based in Hamburg and we have around
40 people working here and we do a bunch
of stuff mostly about building data
Platforms in the cloud for various
clients and to show you some of the
clients we have been working with
um you I I'm guessing you're probably
familiar with at least some of them
and what is interesting if you work in
IT consulting and particularly if you
work in something that is has to do with
a data science Consulting and also AI or
machine learning Consulting is that you
basically face uh the the challenge of
building an ml production system for
like very different kind of setups so
basically every client has their own
history every client has their own data
their own I.T system their own I.T
infrastructure
so you basically learn a lot and you see
many different things and also the way
of how you build out the machine
Learning System that you want to run
into production can be different of
course because you should try to adapt
this to the client needs and what this
means for us is that it's basically a
very good
way of also trying to abstract what kind
of things matter and what is valuable
and also sometimes some very
tedious and
heavy learnings that we had to take when
building ml production systems so I'm
trying to build on this on our
experience what we have seen so far and
try to give you some of these
experiences in this talk so basically
what can you expect from this a very
opinionated take on ML Ops based on our
experience
and I want to kick this discussion off
with basically a statement that I'm
going to try to convince you of and this
is the following so I assume that your
ml apps problem is not so much a
technical problem but it's more an
organizational problem
uh there was a blog post which I kind of
came across very recently by Costas
padales
who claimed who claims that analops is
98 data engineering
I thought that's Obama I'm a data
scientist trying to do envelopes or like
at least I was kind of a data scientist
um and now I'm told that I'm actually
not the right guy and this can all be
achieved by data engineers
but when you read through this blog post
you actually are kind of convinced I
would say at least I was kind of
convinced so there are many things uh
that you have to tackle if you remember
like this
Google
plot with all these boxes a lot of these
components have been already there so
for instance things like data and
pipeline management infrastructure
management deploying and monitoring
applications all of this has been there
before before people were trying to put
machine learning into production
and people call data Engineers or maybe
software Engineers back-end Engineers
whatever you call them they have been
dealing with these kinds of pro problems
for a very long time and there are many
standard ways of how to do this
but obviously
um there's these there are these
remaining two percent
um that are somehow important so
obviously you also need to understand
machine learning and data science and
it's a lot more complex than just
calling uh fit and predict on on a model
uh and if you don't like understand the
logic behind the models then obviously
you are also kind of lost and not even
to mention the business case that you
always also need to take into account
for instance if you think about
monitoring monitoring the the relevant
business kpis for your model is very
important and this has to do with your
machine learning application and also
with the business case you're trying to
solve
but I think the main point here is that
whatever the composition of skills are
the skills are available so I think in
most data teams uh at least in many data
teams that I have seen and in many
companies you have people who know a lot
and who have different skill sets but it
is all a matter of of combining these
skill sets very efficiently and that's
going to help you a lot
and I think another point to consider
here is that
um
we don't need more tools actually there
is an abundance of tools already
available
so if you look at this
this is a plot it's a bit hard to read
but I can just like give you uh I can
just read it out so
um this is from a Blog by chip Yuan who
is a professor at Stanford or at least
lecturer and she um she basically did a
survey on on the ml tooling landscape
and this is from 2020 so this is already
like light years old in machine learning
time
but already since then she she uh
collected more than 284 different tools
for things like data pipeline
infrastructure serving all in one
solution Hardware model training so
basically all the components that are
out there um basically you can find
tools and if you want um you can like
look for her blog and she has a list she
even has a Google sheet with all the
tools available
so I think like
um it's not a matter of much and it's
not so much a matter of like finding
um like that there is a tour missing in
your tool stick it's more a question of
um not using the wrong tool for the
wrong job
and so basically uh what what do you
need to do
um obviously you need to get your skills
and tools organized
and how can you do this
with efficiency and scalability
so now you might wonder what are these
things then efficiency and scalability
and how can they help you
and I think
like
um
to start with efficiency you can think
of these things as kind of design
principles or maybe even some kind of
meta design principles that you can use
to make informed decisions
so we know efficiency already from
systems design
where we basically try for instance when
we try to
implement an algorithm so we want this
algorithm to be as efficient as possible
it could be like a sorting algorithm but
it could also be a machine learning
algorithm so you want this to use very
very little resources you want to be
this you want this to be fast and so on
you can also think think of efficiency
in the systems design perspective in
terms of data structures so for instance
yesterday I heard a talk talk about the
spark connect
component so and there were rdds
mentioned rdd is like a perfect example
for a very
um for for a data structure that is like
very
um
narrowed down to a very proprietary data
structure basically to make things more
efficient
and then you can also also think of
efficiency in terms of parallelizing
your work but I think for ML Ops
efficiency also has another meaning that
is very important and that's basically
the efficiency of the data science
developer
so usually a data scientist wants to be
very quick they want to try out things
very quickly and see if something works
or not and usually our work mode as a
data scientist is not by having like
very deterministic assumptions and then
you know what to build but you have to
try out many things you have to
experiment with your features with your
data with your Transformations
and if you have a high iteration speed
and high experimentation velocity this
is actually gonna
um uh matter a lot for how successful
your whole ml project will be
um so to put this even a little bit more
bluntly one very uh efficient system
could be the kaggle data scientist you
probably heard of Kegel all I guess so
like a data scientist who's working on a
Kegel problem has a very well defined
business problem
has very well-defined data sources you
can just download your data from kaggle
as a CSV file and then basically work on
your local machine and iterate very
quickly on your own in your jupyter
notebook or IDE
and you can make very rapid progress in
the way how you solve this data science
problem
and you can also see it in the results
of these kaggle competitions that people
are usually like the benchmarks are very
high and it's very hard to beat each
other and very close race
but obviously
there's or there's also another twist to
efficiency that you can put into the
picture so you can also think of
maintainability as being a feature of
efficiency so for instance
um if you build something and then you
need to change something you uh want
this code that you have previously
developed to be maintainable and the
Kegel data scientist probably has a hard
time to um I don't know hand over his
The Notebook to another person or to
maintain the code that he um has been
writing
and
maintainability is also antagonistic to
many other design principles so
obviously that's not not the only thing
that counts to be rapid to be efficient
but there are other design principles
that you might want to consider when
building a product
and these are sometimes antagonistic to
this idea of being very efficient so if
you think of robustness of the
robustness of your system you don't want
things to be um
uh you you want to uh to be to be sure
that things are deployed in the same way
you want your code to be tested before
you deploy it so these are also things
that will in the end
um kind of be relevant for your system
but are somehow like slowing you down
your development speed
okay that's about efficiency now let's
switch to scalability here we also have
a notion that we kind of know from
systems design so we have perhaps like
some things like horizontal and vertical
scalability in terms of compute
resources so you can basically scale
your system by adding more resources for
some kind of task or you can make your
resources bigger
um
but also here I think we can make a
twist to it and adapt this to the ammo
Ops sphere and I think what here is most
important is that scalability in terms
of envelopes has to do with
organizational scalability and the
possibility to share knowledge across
users and roles
so for instance it's also very important
that you not only enable other data
scientists to collaborate with you on
your data science problem but also make
your work in a way shareable with people
who have other roles for instance like
data Engineers or Cloud Engineers who
help you by deploying the solutions or
who you are collaborating with on your
ml Ops problem
and um yeah then also a few things that
um that also matter here are also things
like automation validation and
versioning so these will all
um uh factor in or like um help you with
uh with scaling things so automating
tasks making them less um like making
work less redundant is obviously helping
you in scaling your system
uh validating data and um
like early on in validating your system
is also very important and versioning
will help you as well so
um
efficiency and scalability can be
thought of as some kind of design
principles that you can think of that
are important and they are somehow like
moving into different directions I would
say
but they can help you make decisions so
now you might wonder what is he talking
about and how this can actually help so
and uh I will try to make this a little
bit more clear in the next section
um where we are actually talking a
little bit more about tools and
evaluating tools
so first of all like this is kind of the
thing that we as data drivers believe in
so we think that
um like for
perhaps 90 of ml systems the best
solution is to combine open source
source software with Cloud platform
services
I could probably like give another talk
on why this is the case so for now I
will just leave it like that
but what I want to do is just to pick
out a few of the open source components
that we think are very important and
that will kind of nicely add up to Some
Cloud Management Services that we are
also using
okay let's start with the first one
ammo flow I guess some of you have
already been working with mlflow or
perhaps some of you are are using this
on a regular basis we think this is a
very very uh good tool
obviously there are other alternatives
to mlflow but we stick with mlflow
because it's open source you can deploy
it in your own cloud environment and you
can do a lot of stuff with it
and why is it good so it is an
experiment tracking tool it basically
allows you to compare different
experiment runs uh for your machine
learning applications so you can compare
for instance uh different sets of
features you can compare
um different hyper parameter tunings or
you can even compare
um yeah training different models
against and compare these
experimentation runs against each other
and then basically decide which results
are best and which you want to then
later put into production
but it also it also provides you a model
registry and it's a very cool
collaboration tool and now our friends
efficiency and scalability can come in
handy because we can now think okay is
ml Ops something interesting
and I would say yes because it will
basically enhance our efficiency so it
will allow us to be better at
experimentation it will increase
velocity because of this experimentation
tracking component
and it will also help to scale us so it
will also help us to be better at
collaboration with each other because we
can basically for instance see what
other people are doing we can like we
have different com contributors who can
um like submit their experiments for the
same problem and we can compare them
so it basically
um provides a benefit for for these two
components
um yeah just to mention one more aspect
so what I really like about mlflow is uh
the the tracking is nice and the
experimentation but what I really like
are these two later components uh ml
flow models and the model registry
because uh this is going already like a
Step Beyond just experimentation
tracking where you have functionality of
basically also
reviewing what kind of model you want to
put into production based on your
experiment runs so this is sometimes
referred to as the data science pull
requests or data science merge request
and it goes a lot into this direction of
uh deploying models is different from
deploying code because you basically
want to look at
um
visualizations you want to compare
metrics and it's it's it's just
different and ammo flow allows this to
do to allow us to do this
and then another tool that we almost
always use is terraform
so terraform helps us to deploy
infrastructure as code
or to have our infrastructure as code
and deploy this via terraform it allows
us to scale resources and also to be
able to deploy this in in various Cloud
settings so for instance it also helps
you against like vendor login effects
this obviously again is not so much
contributing to your efficiency
because it will make things more
complicated and more complex but it
allows you a lot more scalability in
terms of how you can like add resources
or you can also like scale out to I
don't know different Cloud environments
for instance
and then the last two I want to mention
is Feast which we also really like so
Feast is a feature store it's also open
source and
um
it has I think two features that
contribute a lot to scalability and
that's like the one thing is that it uh
it allows you to scale to real-time
serving so it makes it easier at least
to go from from batch prediction jobs to
streaming jobs
and what I also really like about it is
that it basically allows you to scale
features across teams and uh let me talk
a little bit about what that means so um
Feast is also considered to be like uh
a feature store version 3 or whatever
you call it so it has kind of um
a register for your features and I
really like this register part about it
because
um similar to kind of a data catalog
that you perhaps might have come across
it allows you to store and register
features and especially if you want to
scale out your machine Learning System
to kind of a
like
collaborated with many teams or across
different data science use cases you can
basically share the same feature the
same kind of transformation that you
want to apply to data
with many other data teams so for
instance if you work on one use case and
you basically Implement a feature for
this use case and then you I don't know
start another project and you want to
reuse this feature Feast makes this a
lot easier and will also help you kind
of reduce a boilerplate and redundant
code
yes so in the end
um I think
um envelopes is still hard and even like
having seen many things and trying to
put many machine learning models in
production I can say it's still very
hard and difficult
and I think one of the reasons for why
it is so hard is because we have all
these contradicting design principles so
we want to be very quick in our
experimentation but also we want to make
sure it's robust and yeah this is hard
to handle
but I hope that I at least kind of
convinced you that efficiency and
scalability may help you to solve the
organizational burden of mlops because
they can be used as a guideline for Tool
selection
yeah so with that
um
I can just say there is no single best
approach to mlops and I think finding
your own way and finding what works best
for you is like the the way to go
and I hope like using or thinking of
design principles and finding your way
may help you deploy all your models into
production so thank you and good luck
with your mlops journey
foreign
thank you Paul
nice overview of machine learning
production and envelopes we have some
questions on the slido and you can put
them on slide door still if you cannot
see them to a vote I'm sorry because I'm
approving everything
so
put them try to vote and I'm going to
ask the questions to Paul so do you have
a feeling that there is a serious fear
of missing out in ml Ops base and in
reality people do not need most of those
tools at all
yeah for sure yeah yeah like um I
I gave another talk on envelopes where I
basically said uh um like um Beware of
the model zoo and I think that's very
true because it can be very overming you
see all these new tools popping up and
you
quickly have to decide whether or not
this is something that is important or
relevant for you and this can be very
challenging and I mean what we try to do
is basically stick to as much to build
things as simple as possible and to use
as little tools as possible and to be
very like
thoughtful about putting some new model
into our system
nice you don't want to be changing
everyday tools and so on that's not so
nice yeah so there is a question about
cloud provider which one are you using
and which service are you using to
deploy mlflow okay yeah good point yeah
I didn't mention cloud services so uh we
mostly work on gcp and AWS and we are
using both a sagemaker and vertex AI my
feeling is that gcp is like the services
I like them a little bit better for
machine learning and for mlops so like
if you have to make the decision I would
probably go with gcp right now
okay nice manage Terrace is a good to
end next question what is your
recommendation for model serving with
terraform
I haven't served models with terraform
usually we only serve infrastructure and
the models are served separately yes
it's more for deploying infrastructure
with the code yes
yes and next one what kind of interfaces
do you define between teams like mlflow
artifact or
what kind of what interfaces
between between teams that really
depends on I guess the project
so like
and I'm also struggling if I get the
question right so
I don't think we have interface between
teams or if it's like the deployment I
think like we you can use
let's say models as artifacts between
the training part and the serving part
or yeah yeah usually yeah usually so we
have usually we have like a
uh Docker images for the models and then
basically uh but the model artifacts
themselves we deployed and Via either
ammo flow or sometimes we even use like
sagemaker model registry instead okay
there is a couple of questions about
Data Tracking and versioning what are
you using
so
um sometimes we've just built stuff kind
of by hand uh using also Cloud manager
services
uh we've been looking into DVC which
looks very good
um so yeah so that's probably my
recommendation but it's a lot of work
yeah
true and there are a lot of bunch of
flows Cube flow meta flow ml flow and so
on but how would you go on about
selecting a specific one
uh yeah I mean I think these flows are a
lot very different from each other so uh
uh yeah I like qpro is nice but
um I think especially for teams who are
not yet using kubernetes I wouldn't like
advise to just if you want to solve
envelopes to go into kubernetes because
it's just too hard to manage so you can
use qpro on gcp which is good but if
you're using kubernetes then kubeflow is
obviously a good alternative yeah on top
of it and have you used fist within
databricks if so how does it compared to
databricks building features or that's a
good question no I I don't have any
experience with databricks
okay
um
[Music]
sorry I'm picking the last questions
um how do you choose between using
features from the cloud provider
uh like the serving tracking and so on
and using operations tools
that's a really good question I think
that's becoming more and more difficult
because uh Cloud providers are like more
and more trying to
um
uh integrate functionality from open
source tooling so if you look at
what Google has been doing in the last I
don't know here or something they have
like a lot improved a lot so they you
can also find like experimentation
tracking system kind of and you have
you have a model registry
so um so that's that's really difficult
decision I would I think the main
benefit of using managed Services is
obviously that you don't have to manage
them and I would that's a huge advantage
and I would always kind of
use this in in doubt so like my advice
would be to use open source only when
you really need it
and maybe when you don't have the skills
to manage by yourself
exactly yeah obviously yeah if you have
skills to manage all of this by yourself
then go for it okay based on your
ranking you seems to have optimized for
scalability
was this a conscious choice
um
I mean kind of like
I think like after every project and
every model that you want to deploy you
would you have like the feeling that you
next time you will do something
different you take some learning out of
it so I think for now we're like leaning
more to scalability I guess
um yeah I mean there are other people
who are like using notebooks in
production which is actually a lot more
towards efficiency
but uh yeah we don't do this
okay great thank you for your sharing
your experience
foreign
[Applause]